fish fingers with a delicious chip butty
Secret
of a good chip buddy
is in the potato
now these are Desiree
potatoes one of my first ever jobs
was working in a chip shop I used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which was then the potato peeler
all day long today I'm gonna do
something a bit healthier
for my oven chips with a Twist
simply peel
slice and Blanche for three to four
minutes
drain
season uncover well with Paprika spread
evenly over an oiled baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
simple as that next up easy fish fingers
this is Pollock
a really nice firm delicious fish cut
the fish and finger size battens of fish
put them onto your plate and just
lightly salt them you can do that
literally 20 minutes 30 minutes before
you start cooking the fish
firms the fish up beautifully and it
allows it to become a little more
durable especially in the pan now for
the coating start by thoroughly coating
the fish in seasoned flour and then just
roll it
to get rid of those little sharp corners
because then it stops those Corners
almost burning in a pan
in to your egg wash
and really coat them
wonderful
and then this is Dill goes brilliantly
well with the fish
and run the deal through my breadcrumbs
that makes it more aromatic
lay them
onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip butty
nothing wrong with fish fingers
let's give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry and they'll need around three
minutes on each side
I want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first and then we'll flip them over
and finish them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan
a nice
little knob of butter
that'll work wonders where the
breadcrumbs and the deal
nice and carefully
take them out
hey look and smell incredible
stay nice and crispy
now to assemble my chip buddy starting
with button thick crusty bread
foreign
mop up that amazing flavor
on
slice in half never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on with a ship buddy there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that I've never
forgotten the joy I've come for food but
my God that makes me feel like a
nine-year-old
excuse me for one moment
I want to stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers are my ultimate
chip buddy so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing cooking scrummy
sardines topped with a fragrant
gremolata dressing but first a
deliciously fresh orzo pasta salad this
is one of the Hidden Delicacies of
Italian pasta also because 90 of the
time it's always hidden in a soup or a
brothel minestrone and it looks like
large grains of rice but once they
absorb that water they double in size
It's a pasta that needs a lot of help
season it nicely pinch of salt and
splash of extra virgin olive oil fresh
bay leaf into the boiling water and that
bay leaf really helps to flavor the
pasta give you a little pan
turn left and right that stops any pasta
sticking to the bottom and the secret
behind cooking any pasta is having a
nice gentle rolling boil you just have
the gas up where the outside of the pan
is just rolling and all that also is
tumbling over each other gently boiling
past the rapidly tends to destroy the
outside texture it doesn't take the
marinade or the vinaigrette or the sauce
for the dressing parmesan Twist of fresh
pepper the zest of the lemon I'll
squeeze your lemon in there through your
fingers to catch all those seeds bring
that together with some extra virgin
olive oil
foreign s taste delicious toasting them
just elevates them
after eight minutes my orzo is perfectly
al dente
train it a little bit of cold water
through it close the cooking process
down let's stop it from going mushy it's
the size of pumpkin seeds now a drizzle
of olive oil and into the vinaigrette
whilst it's still warm just above room
temperature because the warmer the pasta
the more it absorbs the vinaigrette and
now some texture rocket not finely
chopped
on the fresh basil as well
roll them up like a big fat cigar slice
in half
and then chop the basil
crunch just sprinkle the toasty pine
nuts
it looks like a plate of jewels glistens
it's delicious very fragrant also pasta
salad now for sardines incredibly
healthy an absolutely delicious grilled
never ever be intimidated on looking for
fresh fish it's about the condition of
the fish Bright Eyes fresh gills nice
bright red interior and the firmness of
the flesh almost you could stand the
fish up on his own it needs to be that
fresh the best way to get flavor into
sardine just to grill it light seasoning
olive oil
and just roll the seasoning around
get your Rosemary peel off a few of the
little shards at the end so it's a
little bit sharp push the Rosemary in
almost like a Threading makes them so
much more flavoursome
they'll be scared of those fine little
bones I remember growing up with
sardines tin sardines you didn't tongue
your nose up at the bone once The
Griddle pan starts to smoke lightly
drizzle and then sardines on
two and a half for three minutes each
side
now for the gremlinata a vinaigrette
that sits beautifully well on the
sardines freshly fastly just run the
knife once nothing worse when you over
chop parsley and all that delicious
flavors left on the board the zest and
juice of an orange and the lemon
turn them now
grandma that's about fragrance natural
flavors
brilliant for grilled Meats as well a
little touch of salt
and pepper
and then olive oil just to bring it
together
the garlic I almost want to be like a
secret weapon in there
raise it
bring that together you've got a very
fresh clean gremolata almost if we're
sat on the Amalfi Coast
off
then once the sardines are still nice
and warm and just thinly coat the
gremolata I'd like to pass in the garlic
to sit on top and that's citrus from the
lemon and the orange to sort of dive
underneath
see why Italian cuisine rides on the
freshest and the simplest execution
they allow their ingredients to become
the hero
not the chef
also salad with stunning grilled
sardines
[Music]
wherever you eat this dish it will fill
your senses with the sun and the Sea of
the Mediterranean delicious
[Music]
foreign